the force giveth and taketh away that's
the lesson poor man doe learns in the
newest chapter of the mandalorian the
episodes title sanctuary sets up that
classic bittersweet trope of all great
western films the cowboy rolls into a
one-horse town fixes problems only
people on the frontier could possibly
experience and becomes beloved we of
course know exactly how this is going to
end because the Mandalorian is literally
a man with no name at the episodes
conclusion he's ready to ascend once
more to the stars and continue following
his compulsion to roam but it may not be
all sunsets and solitaire endings after
all because the child has been found by
one more of the endless for tracking him
and sanctuary has been spoiled were left
again with the mandalorian and the child
in the middle of a wistful departure and
no idea where the next chapter may lead
we can gather now that this is part of
the points of the series his first
season to keep us feeling as lost and
confused as a hero must be searching his
star charts for the next planet to stave
off the inevitable
but as mando grows more obviously
attached to his one time bounty and the
consequences of his betrayal of his
guild begin to stack up how does this
end in anything other than tragedy the
Mandalorians fourth episode introduced
us to cara dune former rebellion soldier
turned outlaw mercenary who is a little
rougher around the edges than mando it
was a bit of a surprise to have her drop
into mandos life then see him say
goodbye to her by the episodes end when
we know we're going to see her again but
honestly that only builds all the more
intrigue around the character well then
until our paths cross till her paths
cross we're pleased to see she hasn't
been immediately relegated to potential
love interest and that she might just
grow into the role of mandos actual
butt-kicking BFF provided there are no
last-minute betrayals on her part mando
may not be allowed a permanent home with
a white picket fence but for crying out
loud
let him have friends Cara doon also
provides a really great narrative
opportunity an external foil from mandos
feelings up until now we've had to
process most of his emotions purely
through his body language and while
actor Pedro Pascal is doing a
magnificent job communicating what's
going on underneath his helmet with
almost no dialogue
the conceit does leave interpretive gaps
by its very nature
endo and Kara are immediately presented
as simpatico through the time-honored
trope of morally gray characters
fostering friendship through fistfights
[Applause]
she lives the rough-and-tumble life too
and understands that mando does want a
simpler existence though she does not
understand why he refuses it when it's
offered we're looking forward to seeing
the two meet again and hopefully not on
opposite sides of some conflict
sanctuary taught us quite a bit about
mandos motivations earlier we discussed
the trope of cowboys and dusty towns
they're tempted to remain in jokes aside
the idea of a permanent home is
something mando pretty clearly wants and
actively denies himself this applies to
poles in this episode he denies even the
possibility of connecting with O'Meara
on a more personal level and initially
decides to leave baby Yoda in the care
of the village before everything goes
wrong why because of his debt to the
Mandalorian people and we can now say
with certainty that the Mandalorian is
not well a Mandalorian as in not from
Mandalore and the surrounding colony
planets he is taught in their warrior
traditions and observes their faith and
that is clearly all that matters to what
we presume are the actual Mandalorians
he has previously interacted with but he
was originally of another race or
heritage as a foundling before being
rescued by the Mandalorians no doubt he
feels a huge debt to these people for
giving him his life and the best
possibility of surviving on the edge of
the galaxy but there also was a rather
pregnant pause before mando said he was
happy the Mandalorians gave him the life
they did he also initially rebuffs
Kara's assertion that leaving baby Yoda
behind in the village even for his own
benefits will break his tiny green parts
with the stoic response he'll get over
it
we all do man down buddy you've loaded
up that big old transport with half the
guns in the parsec and that's still less
baggage than whatever's going on in that
chrome dome of yours but that inner
conflict makes sense doesn't it mando
wants to honor the gifts he's been given
but if he's not of the Mandalorians as a
people and his suddenly feeling torn
from the responsibilities he has acted
under for many years that could create a
pretty significant crisis of identity he
works incredibly hard to be what he is
and to live up to the mandala
standard what happens when life tempts
him from it that inner conflict isn't
going away because the child is coming
with him and that connection between
them is only going to grow for better or
for worse check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]